Up first this hour is Gonna be Larry in Tacoma, Washington. Hey, larry. How are ya?
Hey morning Dave. How are you doing? Better than I deserve. What's up in your world?
well, Umm...
So right now. I'm actually in the beginning, and I fell hard times and staying in my car
but I'm reading your book and it's very motivating and it's really common sense, so I'm about to start a job and
I'm motivated, and I want to take care of that in a future deficit and
Wow, what's your new job?
I got a government job that I bless so although I
fell on hard times I have a I'm anticipating this job, so
I'll be working for the government for D.O.T.
Okay, very cool. Making what kind of money?
About Forty five hundred a month. Wow, when do you start?
Hopefully, I start I do my drug test and screening in two and a half weeks. They called me last week
They looked over my credentials
And whatnot so, we're kinda headed in that direction
Excellent, excellent, good for you. So did I hear you right? You said you're living in your car
Yea, I'm living in my car, reading your book and
It's very hopeful you know, it's a lot of common sense of practical things but
Been just so naive and ignorant in terms of finances and me personally made a lot of bad choices, but as I read your book and
Get more in depth of it. It's uh it's very
Very hopeful and I thank the lord for that. Good well, praise God man. It sounds like you're getting it turned around
I'm proud of you. Very well done
There's always a light at the end the tunnel that's not a train, right?
right, that's right
So, uh, how old are you?
31. Okay, and you're single I take it? Well yeah because of my bad decisions. I am today. But umm..
it's life. You don't have to, but I'm just curious
Because I don't get a lot of calls like this. What were your bad decisions that put you in the car?
Oh man, first  and foremost, I'm not trying to get religious on all the callers and everyone
But, just not doing God's will, you know, just plain and simple in that regard
but then I made poor choices many of poor choices with my
finances. With credit card debt, I had a auto loan
and I financed, that got repo and
While I'm talking to you, thing is, this car that I have now, it could get repo'd if I don't start this job
Sooner than later. So I'm kind of in a dilemma. Mm-hmm
And how much debt do you have now?
Well, I did my budget yesterday. I bought a big
bulletin board from Dollar Tree, which is only a dollar and I'm in the
27,000
Okay, 27,000 how much of that's the car?
I think about 11,000, I got two student loans that accumulate to about 6,000,
and I got
that credit card debt. Mm-Hmm. Okay, good, good
Yeah, you're gonna blow through that real fast making 4,500 your life's not gonna change just a little bit
It's Gonna change Freakin dramatically dude
I mean absolutely
amazing so uh
What's your living plans for the next two and a half weeks just the car and then start work out of the car or you
Got something else figured out? I've been staying in the car for about two months now, but one day at a time
so hopefully in the next two weeks, I'll
Be in the car, but I'll eat a little better. You know
Okay, that's cool. Is the shelter there helping you in the area?
Yeah, yeah
I go to church also
More so I go to the church
I try not to just go anywhere because there's a lot of crazy people. You know the world. We live in today
Absolutely. I gotta watch where I go. Absolutely. So the bad choices you made, any of those involve substance abuse?
Yeah, alcoholism.
How long you been dry?
Oh man, about four and a half months. Way to go dude!
Well done!
Well done! One day at a time
Well, you're turning it you're turning it you've identified the the steps you've got to take to turn it around and you're doing the right
things and
I'm proud of you. How can I help you?
Well, no
I just wanted to say thank you because I came across your total money makeover book from my sister-in-law and
I'm in the middle of it, and everything makes sense
And I look at my credit cards and just two days ago
I cut it and I look at all my finances. I'm like, man,
I put myself in this predicament, but there's light at the end of the tunnel as you made mention of so
I'm very motivated and inspired
By your book and I wanted to say thank you. Yeah, well thank you. I'm motivating inspired by you dude
You're doing all the right stuff after having done all the wrong stuff
So, you can't ask any more of a man than that and you squared your shoulders,
And you face the demons down, you turned the corner. I'm very very proud of you
I want you to go through our class Financial Peace University, and I want to pay for it
They'll be one taught in a local church there that we can get you plugged into I'll put you on hold and Kelly
will pick up and
Do me a favor as you're going through that class call me back this fall and tell me
Tell some of our listeners and me the story of how this is continuing to turn around. You're inspiring, dude.
Hey, thanks Dave. Thanks all you folks over there. As I contemplated about calling. What I said hey
I'm starting then I do I definitely wanted to call you when everything that's better and make progress. Yeah, cool
We want to hear the follow-up on your life, man. You're doing good stuff. Hold on Kelly
Will pick up and we'll get you signed up for financial Peace university that's something we can do to help you lift
And you stay plugged into your local church here, and they'll walk you
Straight into that new job and straight into the new life that's ahead of you. Very well done sir, very well done
Hey guys
Thanks for watching if you enjoyed this video click the subscribe button
To get the latest content and check out these other great clips from the show